hey guys welcome back to the channel are
you experiencing a reading slump do you
find it hard to finish or even start a
single book
yeah that's me do you ever read half a
page and start feeling your eyes
skimming over the words
when you turn off the light to go to
sleep do you dream of that book you
haven't finished as it's being guarded
by the demon pazuzu and when you attempt
to retrieve the book from him do his
piercing red eyes lull you into a state
of waking paralysis wherein you can't
discern the passing of time
what the [ __ ] when you wake up and make
breakfast do you frequently spill your
coffee still shaken by your encounter
with the demon pazuzu and when you call
in sick to work does your boss simply
repeat the phrase pazuzu
when you peer into the mirror at night
do you almost yearn for the coming of
pazuzu for his sweet embrace when you
pick up that book you've been desperate
to finish do you wish you could just
surrender well if you do i suggest
locking down like 15 pages a day it's
nice to take small chunks you know i
suggest going to the library checking
out some new releases and just
experiment a little bit and as always
guys thank you so much for watching i
hope these tips help please hit that
like and subscribe button i'm so
grateful for you for all of my amazing
patrons you are my heroes thank you guys
so much have a good one
is it over
please let me go
please i have a family